Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene is being accused
of veiled racism
after a shouting match
with Democrat Jamaal Bowman.
The argument was over
the potential expulsion of indicted
Republican Congressman George Santos
The party has to kick him out.
Allison, your party is hanging
by a killer.
We've got to get rid of the party.
The point is, hey, are you ready?
The other side already.
Listen, no more to
the party.
The congresswoman suggested
she felt physically threatened by Bowman
because he was a
had a, quote, history of aggression.
Listen,
what concerns me about Jamaal Bowman
is he has a history of aggression.
What's on video
as Jamaal Bowman
shouting at the top
of his lungs, cursing,
calling me a horrible
and calling me a white supremacist,
which I take great offense to.
That is like calling a person of color
the N-word, which should never happen.
Calling me a white
supremacist is equal to that.
And I am concerned about
I feel threatened by him.
She was likely hearkening
back to this incident last month
and the rhetoric that helped with
white supremacy.
We are pushing back against that
in all its forms.
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
these are take her ass
back to Washington.
This was Congressman Bowman's response
to what Greene has said
Unfortunately, this country has a history
of characterizing black men
who are outspoken,
who stand their ground
and who push back as being threatening
or intimidating.
So she's not even using a dog whistle.
She's using a bullhorn
to put a target on my back.
I never invaded her personal space.
I was laughing and gregarious
the entire time.
How was that intimidating?
Unfortunately, white
supremacists, historically,
this is what they do
Here's why he's saying that.
This is some important context
you should know.
Greene is the same person
who chased down
a teenage survivor of Florida's
deadliest school shooting
who was on the hill
advocating for gun control. Watch.
You don't have anything.
You don't have anything to say
to yourself.
I can't defend your stance.
How did you get
with Sanders?
And this February, Greene spoke
at a white
nationalist conference organized
by well-known white supremacist
Nick Fuentes.
All right.
Let's bring in the table
Eric Deggans,
TV and media analyst for NPR,
CNN's Elina, TREENE.
Jamal Simmons,
former communications director
to vice president
Harris, and Rena
Shaw, a Republican strategist.
All right.
I'm going to start with you, Jamal.
There is.
Can we just call out the hypocrisy here?
When you saw that,
what did you see between the two of them?
Because we can all watch it.
It's not like it's
something that happened in the dark
and nobody saw it but the two of them.
You can see what's going on there.
Yeah.
Listen, it wasn't
the most sophisticated a debate.
Whenever we saw on Capitol Hill,
we can articulate that. Right.
But what was concerning
was that Congresswoman
Taylor Green would say that
she felt threatened
by someone who, as you said,
was laughing with sort of gesturing,
was in the middle of a crowd of people.
She also said he's not smart.
Jamaal Bowman has a doctorate
in education
founded a school, led
a school for ten years.
It all, as he said,
goes back to not just dog whistles,
but these pretty loud
clarion calls to racism
And the thing about Marjorie Taylor
Greene, unlike George Santos, right.
Who this was all kind of staged
because of the George Santos debate
that was happening on the Hill today,
George Santos is a fraud.
I mean, everybody can sort of
see that he's not really who it is
he pretends to be.
Marjorie Taylor Greene is not a fraud.
She's exactly who she pretends to be.
She's scary.
She's a Christian nationalist.
She says that about 10% in America
of Americans, according to PR,
I believe that America should
be a Christian nation only.
And she
said that
that January six
would be our 1776 moment.
So somebody who before
and when we had the violence
of January six
saw that as a moment
for a new kind of America to be founded,
I think sees the scary one
out of the exchange that we saw today.
I want to ask you, Rena,
what you made of that,
and you can all jump in
when this is a conversation.
I want you to.
But, you know, we know from
from reporting from from
CNN and everyone else's reporting that
that Greene
repeatedly indicated support
for executing prominent
Democratic politicians
in 20, 16 and 29th history.
20, 18, 20, 19
before she was elected to Congress.
And now she's making this accusation
that just doesn't seem credible.
Yeah,
there's a lot to unpack here
for someone
who's sitting in
a member of Congress post.
It's it's almost shocking to me.
I'm a two time
former senior congressional staffer
and over a decade ago.
But I'll tell you,
this was fast
how we got here to see this
kind of extremism
and to see,
again, a sitting member of Congress
weaponize their words on the regular.
But when she thinks
somebody else is doing
the tactics
she employs are not just nonsensical,
they're dangerous
because it's what about ism
and then it's wrapped up in racism.
It's plain and simple.
She doesn't reflect the vast
majority of white conservative
women in this country.
She doesn't reflect their views.
She doesn't reflect the views of the vast
majority of conservative women.
And I submit to you
that the more she continues says
we'll be able to see her real ambition.
And I think we already see some of it.
She does these incidents.
She goes at them alone
because she fundraises off of them.
You don't see any of her colleagues
the ones who look like her, women
in the GOP in the House chamber
rushing to her defense.
Because what I saw in that incident
was a heated discussion
between two colleagues.
Was it civil?
I think it was
But what it indicated
is that she and many others
also on the other side of the aisle,
I'm not going to see into equal amounts
or in the same way.
But I want to say that
we do see this declining civility
in the body of Congress,
and that is most dangerous for us
because that indicates
higher levels of disgust.
I'm sorry.
They're going to get less done
and higher levels of dissatisfaction
with Congress.
That's right.
That's it.
Jamal, what do you make of this
when you look at the tropes?
Ah, sorry, Eric.
When you make of the tropes
and sort of today that
I remember when
now there
is certainly a way cooler names there
that but, you know, well,
one of the things that struck me
is that one of the things that we see
with white supremacists
is that they do
try to take on the mantle of issues
that have worked
for civil rights advocates. Right.
So this idea that trying to find a term
that's supposedly as offensive
as the N-word
and saying well,
they use that word against me,
you know,
that was something
that was really troubling
because the N-word, there's a reason why
we don't say that word.
I mean,
so you can tell that that
phrase, white
supremacist, isn't the same as the N-word
because we say white supremacy.
We do not say the N-word.
And the N-word has a certain history
that's wrapped up
in the legacy of slavery.
And that's also something
that a lot of white supremacists
want to avoid.
They don't want to talk about
the impact of hundreds
of years of chattel slavery
involving black people
and the modern legacy of that.
And so it's so hard to see her in one
breath, want to back away the hypocrisy
of criticizing
someone who uses the same tactics
she does,
and then also trying to back away
the legacy of slavery
and the weight of the N-word
by trying to compare
calling her a white supremacist,
which is that, you know, she's arguably
which is arguably
something you could accuse her of
and comparing it to something as terrible
as the N-word does.
And then finally, we're in a situation
where I do feel like
the problem is
that people like her and her tactics,
it can pull other people
down to that level.
And it really bothers me
that a legislator who seems, you know,
as you said, really intelligent
and accomplished
would be drawn into a shouting match
with someone like that anyway.
I think
one of the things you have to realize
is that
you can't fight that same fight because
all it does
is bring you down to their level.
Well, you know what else
that does, Elena?
It sometimes is used in a different way.
How much of this do you see when you see
something like that
will be turned around
and used for fundraising?
Because I certainly get the things
from a whole bunch of different folks
who will use that.
MS.
Greene herself to raise money.
Oh, absolutely. Absolutely.
I think that's something that
to give Marjorie Taylor
Greene credit,
she knows
how to message
on these things effectively,
and she knows that it plays very well
with the Trump base
and her base and the MAGA voters.
And it's definitely something
I think we could likely see
in some fundraising appeals.
I also think
that as this plays out, I mean, her
jumping on this,
holding a press conference today
about the incident
and also distorting some of the facts.
I mean,
I spoke with some of my colleagues
who were on the steps of the Capitol,
and they said they were there.
They saw the entire interaction.
They did not
hear any
of the words
she described about the nastiness of it
and and calling her
a white supremacist in that moment.
We obviously saw the video of him
doing it in New York. But
but that's something that
her supporters love about her.
And I think also at the same time,
it's also turning she's not just,
you know,
as much as she is
a far right member of Congress
and a very fringe member of Congress,
she also has a lot of sway
within the Republican Party.
She meets weekly with Kevin Miller.
I mean, as of January,
she's got a direct right.
The speaker
she's had it before then, though.
I mean, she's been meeting weekly
with the speaker.
And so she has a lot of power.
And so
it's fascinating to watch how she can
monopolize on moments
that power flows
directly from these kinds
of confrontations with the confrontation,
because that money has put her
as the subject of a segment on CNN.
Yeah.
And I guess the question is, I can't help
but assess.
I'm sorry I'm going along.
But Rina,
why doesn't the party
take care of this deal
with her in the way
in which she should be dealt with
in a lot of people's minds?
They can't do it
because she's a celebrity now.
That's the thing.
She represents a sort of growing, iconic
right figure. And it's not right. But.
And it's not fair to the moderates.
Okay. I'll be very honest.
But it has everything to do
with money and stardom
and where she goes.
She commands an audience,
and she draws in those small donors
because she gets them excited
and she gets them
fearful about the future.
And remember,
she's got Donald Trump on speed dial.
Oh, I know. Thank you so much.